there is a massive reduction in the
amount of short terms that people are
having and also you have declining
marriage rates and family rates the
number of men reporting Us in the last
year has tripled from eight percent to
28 from 2008 to 2018 this is men between
the ages of 18 and 30. short terms has
declined it's also declined for women as
well but a little bit more for men for
the first time in history 50.1 percent
of women are childless at 30 and a
report from Reuters says that 45 of
prime working age women between 22 and
45 will be single and childless by 2040.
what that map shows is short terms and
long-term mating seem to be on the
decline which is crazy in a world of
tender and Facebook and Instagram
correct how is the ease of access to
other partners increasing while what
actually occurs in the real world seems
to be dropping down